after firing up a lost 80s survival
horror game a young coder unleashes a
hidden curse that tears reality apart
forcing her to make terrifying decisions
and face deadly consequences today on
cinema recapped i'll show you choose or
die from netflix
the film begins with a man on his
computer when suddenly a game appears
and shows him two options to choose from
like turning his bedroom lights on or
off and whatever he chooses happens in
real life the man is very surprised and
at one point the computer asks him in
writing to choose between the tongue or
the ears to which the man is very
confused and decides not to choose
anything however the computer starts to
write choose or die and then emits a
very annoying sound so the man ends up
choosing the tongue to make the noise
stop everything grows silent the man
decides to go to the kitchen and there
he realizes that his wife has just cut
out his son's tongue and at that precise
moment the computer shows that level one
has been completed
months later a girl named kayla finishes
her shift and visits a friend named
isaac they talk about the money problems
they both have and fantasize about the
day that isaac develops his own video
game the two start to clean the room and
kayla finds a box for a video game that
promises to give a lot of money to
whoever wins it they doubt this offer is
still valid because the video game looks
very old but either way they decide to
meet in a cafe to try it out kayla goes
home where her mother is very depressed
because her little son kayla's younger
brother recently died that night kayla
goes to the cafe and realizes her friend
has stood her up so she decides to try
the game by herself kayla puts the game
on her computer and when it opens we see
that it is the same one that we saw at
the beginning of the movie the computer
shows two options coffee or cake kayla
out of curiosity decides to choose
coffee and at that moment a waitress
appears out of nowhere and begins to
serve her coffee kayla is surprised but
thinks it was just a coincidence then
the game asks her if she wants a break
or not and kayla gets a little scared by
the question she decides to close the
computer but when she does it everything
turns dark and a voice tells her to
choose or die
kayla decides to open the computer again
and not knowing what to do she chooses
take a break at that moment the waitress
begins to break glass cups on the floor
then the game asks if the waitress
should continue breaking glasses or
clean up kayla chooses clean up and the
waitress begins to eat the glass on the
floor kayla gets scared and decides to
try to stop her at that moment kayla
wakes up at her room and thinks it was
all a dream however she soon realizes
that there's a policeman talking to her
mother and he mentions that the waitress
incident was real later kayla leaves her
house and she runs into a neighbor who's
very bad he begins to harass her and
makes fun of her mother's situation to
which kayla decides not to pay any
attention and quickly goes to look for
her friend isaac once at her friend's
house kayla asked him where he got the
game since they found the disc in his
room however isaac replies that it was
already in the room when he went to live
there kayla goes to work that night and
receives a call from her mother who
tells her that she's very scared because
she hears rats at the house
kayla tries to calm her down and
suddenly sees one of the work computers
turning on and showing the game again
the girl realizes the plans of her house
are on the screen as if it were a video
game and she has to choose where a giant
rat should go knowing that her mother is
in one of the rooms kayla tries to
divert the rat from reaching the room
where her mother is but ends up losing
control and the rat approaches the room
very hungrily kayla tells her mom on the
phone to jump out the window to save
herself and when she does the game shows
that level 2 has been completed and that
tomorrow she must play again at the same
time the next day kayla is taking care
of her mother in the hospital since she
suffered a lot of injuries after jumping
out the window later kayla decides to
see their apartment and realizes that
all the damage caused by the rat was
real and when she's about to leave she
runs into the neighbor again who begins
to propose inappropriate things to her
making her even angrier later kayla
visits her friend isaac and tells him
everything that's happening to her and
shows him photos of her destroyed
apartment as evidence her friend
believes her the two decide to wait
together for the time of the next game
to see if they can discover something
the time comes and the game begins by
mentioning that it knows that kayla is
accompanied isaac is shocked to see this
and gets more shocked to see that the
computer writes down everything he says
even before he says it at that moment
the game asks if isaac should help or
not and then emits a very annoying sound
to pressure kayla to choose kayla
chooses yes and just at that moment two
doors appear on the wall of the room one
red and one blue the game asks them to
choose one of them and both friends
decide to go through the red one the
door opens and the friends enter when
suddenly kayla hears the voice of her
late brother she decides to follow the
sound and ends up entering a pool full
of fog they separate and get lost kayla
realizes that the sound is produced by a
doll and just that moment she hears
isaac's voice screaming for help kayla
looks for her friend and when she finds
him she sees his body lying next to her
brothers she gets very scared and that
moment some letters appear over the
bodies they make her choose between
saving her friend or her brother kayla
reacts and realizes this cannot be her
brother so she decides to choose her
friend and just at that moment the body
of the brother rises and begins to
attack her kayla tries to defend herself
and has no choice but to end the false
brother with her own hands to survive
later the two friends appear in the room
again as if nothing had happened and
they realized that the game shows that
level 3 has been completed the next day
kayla and isaac start to investigate
more about the game and since they know
programming they managed to hack it and
end up getting an address the two
friends decide to go there and realize
that it is an abandoned warehouse they
look all over the place and when
checking some computers they find an old
recording they watch the recording and
see a man who explains that he found
some very powerful symbols which can be
used to hurt other people as a footwork
curse the man explains that he managed
to understand these symbols and
translated them into a programming
language with that he managed to create
a cursed video game then the man says
that he being the creator obtains
benefits through the pain of others and
shows an example where he forces another
man to play making him suffer and we see
that the creator obtains so much
strength that he even heals a wound in
his arm at that moment the creator of
the game changes his posture and starts
talking directly to the camera saying
that level 4 has started and then he
knows that kayla and isaac are cheating
isaac is quite surprised because was
supposed to be a recording he decides to
unplug the computer and just at that
moment he feels his whole body slip from
reality into fiction as if he were a
character inside the game then the
creator of the game asks kayla if she
should go back or forward in time kayla
chooses to go forward and sees her
friend begin to spit videotape out of
his mouth he ends up falling to the
ground badly injured kayla quickly
approaches isaac but realizes that he
died after a few seconds and just at
that moment the game shows the level 4
has been completed later kayla sees that
the game indicates some coordinates she
decides to go there and when she arrives
she finds a house in the middle of the
forest kayla decides to go in and finds
a family which is the one from the
beginning of the movie kayla tells him
that she's playing the cursed game to
which the man replies that he also
played it three months ago the man
explains that the game also hurt them
but that he made a deal with the creator
and sent many copies of the game to
different places on the condition that
he leaves them alone and we see that the
wife and son ended up very badly injured
by the game
just then kayla receives a game
notification on her phone indicating
that the final level has begun and that
she must defeat the final boss
the man realizes the game wants kayla to
kill him and he gets very angry since he
said that he wanted to be the hero of
the game kayla and the man start to
fight but they soon realize that each
feels what happens to the other that is
if kayla receives a hit she does not
feel anything but the man does at that
moment the man's family enters the fight
and they start beating him since they're
angry with him for everything that's
happened although we see that the one
who feels all the pain is really kayla
then kayla decides to go to the yard and
jumps into the pool causing the man to
end up drowned the man's family decides
to save kayla from the water and help
her heal her wounds as thanks for ending
him and just at that moment kayla
receives a notification from the game it
tells her that she's won and that she
will receive the prize a couple of days
go by and we see that the prize the
killer received is absolute control of
the game so now she's the one who can
make other people suffer kayla soon uses
this power to play with the neighbor who
bothered her and ends up making him die
by putting his face on several needles
immediately kaler receives power enough
from the neighbor's suffering to end up
healing the wound she got during the
fight on the last level then kayla
receives a call from the creator of the
game who asks her what she will do with
the power to which she replies only that
you will play with those who deserve it
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best horror movies
thanks for watching